let's get to it
which doesn't belong in y we do it on a
weekly basis or there are bouts
three teams three people three anything
and we come up with the reason why one
of them just doesn't fit let's start
with three teams that have bad defenses
seahawks cowboys and vikings peter which
doesn't belong and why
seahawks because
uh in my opinion their defense
three weeks from now
is going to be significantly better than
it is today and i don't necessarily
think those other teams you can say it i
say that because they're going to have
snax harrison in the middle of their
line playing 20 to 25 snaps
uh of premier run defense okay
and then
you're gonna have jamal adams back from
his groin injury so to me
that's getting
two
all-pro players at their job back for
the meteor schedule
yeah you know i'm inclined to agree with
you on that and also i won't be
surprised if they try to make some sort
of a move with some sort of a team that
may be ready to fold the tents and trade
a pass rusher i feel like there's going
to be an urgency by the seahawks to even
get better for the cowboys it's more
about trying to find the right mix
between new system and players who are
there for a different system vikings you
got a lot of older guys and then you got
these young corners that are thrust into
service and the system relies on great
corner play and they just don't have it
now seahawks i agree they're going to be
a better defense because they'll have
adams they'll have harrison and i won't
be surprised if they make a deal at the
trade deadline to try to get a pass
rusher from someone all right three one
win teams bengals dolphins jaguars which
doesn't belong and why
uh the miami dolphins because last year
in the second half of the season the
dolphins proved that
they're in it for the long haul and they
played great after halloween last year
but i think the one thing that they have
to do whether it be i mean
look i think we all believe that ryan
fitzpatrick is on borrowed time
i think that they're going to get a jolt
of energy
and a jolt of goodness quite honestly
when they put tuatanga velo in the
lineup and i would expect that to happen
sometime in the next two weeks
i'm gonna go bengals because that's the
one of the three teams where they've got
their quarterback he's awesome
and he's gonna turn the franchise around
and they can take some solace in that no
matter how bad they are this year with
the dolphins we don't know because we
haven't seen tua with the jaguars the
jury's still out on what gardner-menchie
is going to be because they've lost
three in a row all right real quickly
two and two teams saints cardinals 49ers
which doesn't belong and why
i think the cardinals don't belong i
thought they would
you know i thought this was a turning
point season for him but mike you know
what really worries me about the
cardinals right now this is not the same
running game as a year ago a year ago
kenyon drake came in 5.2 a carry this
year after a month 3.8 to carry the
running game is different that sets up
everything for kyler murray and it's
just not the same
i think the saints don't belong because
as you said earlier when they get
michael thomas back they're going to be
able to put pedal to the metal and
they're going to separate from all the
500 teams and that's when it becomes a
two-team race in the nfc south between
new orleans and tampa bay to win that
division and maybe have a shot at
getting the only buy in the nfc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports